hey how's it go and I have collected
some of the finest animation you have
ever seen if you have glasses then put
them on right now if you happen to have
a wine next to you and then take a big
old slurp
[Music]
what is this marina Joy's animation
there's nothing weird about it I don't
understand
dancing inspires me most in life it
makes me feel good it makes me next
video hello Jimmy I love you
I am going to make a delicious dinner
meal Jimmy your mom is dead I do an
order of pizza for a dinner Jimmy no
Jimmy no time for father-son bonding
bonding with me Jimmy it's the pizza or
smaller pizza great the pizza is
aggressive oh [ __ ]
the pizza is aggressive [ __ ] don't
you just hate when your dad dies from an
aggressive Pizza just another day in the
life of Jimmy Neutron animation it's a
wonderful thing you can create whatever
you want some people decide to make this
Oh someone found the footage of my
childbirth my baby's gonna make it big
one day oh sure he's got a lady
she almost got a big nose as I had great
they're great just ain't nothing gonna
top that one
Jesus Christ man Bhutan a provocateur
Bhutan animation entertain the first
ever 3d animation film produced in
return what the [ __ ] is Bhutan hey check
your priveledge you blonde haired ball
bag I am from Bhutan that's where your
friend you're from batad yes I was born
there nine years before the great dragon
war of Bhutan took my family from me
a great Greece cast her spell Oh
oh wow it's a kingdom by China
[Music]
oh I love this one a lot of Sun this
animation is made in 5 fps
[Music]
it's too fast
well I just happen to be walking by nice
to you to love look at them Teddy's
going left is right
[Music]
Pepa I know what happened to our parents
no I already told you they died in a car
accident George how many times I told
you not to go to the basement
just tell me have our fathers arm got
cooked already
no but the freezer is broken why do I
get sexual undertones on this this needs
to stop George I guess it's time for
your drama man what something no other
sister would ever stop that you're a bit
stressed just let me do my thing
[Music]
[Applause]
that's a good bullish I gotta say okay
this needs a little bit of context so
someone made this animation by themself
to announce that they're getting a baby
let's just watch
[Music]
take the pain away